have you always been a good decision
maker do you have like a process when it
comes to that because you probably have
to make decisions pretty quick yeah no I
just go with my gut like uh
I always view it
sort of Family Feud style like you know
if you watch the Family Feud you got the
head guy at the table right oh yeah and
then everyone shouts the answers at them
if you hear a good answer you're like
all right I'll go with that guy but even
if they have the right answer but in my
gut I'm like no I got the right answer
I'll go with mine I may get the X but it
that's kind of how it is it's all gut
based yeah yeah there's no
it it
I look at this I follow my gut since I
started we've been wildly successful a
lot a lot of breaks that I could never
dreamed of and I didn't start parcel
really to like be here I just didn't
want to hate my job waking up in the
morning but uh why would I stop
following my gut it's got us this far so
dude you've done a really good job of
like hiring like really neat Talent like
guys like Caleb uh big cat who's your
you know I don't know if you hired him
or he was a partner no no he hired him
okay yep
um you know Glenny balls
um wow was there Caleb
big cat and Glenny balls putting in
getting put in that category is pretty
[__] high level they're making some
better guys I don't know and big Freddie
or whatever who's the guy that's inside
the tank yeah that guy yeah listen we've
hired uh I bet the under on him huh he's
a big dude he'll surprise you though
that's like you don't think he can fit
in an airplane seat and he can't so
he'll he'll get a point uh we have Jenna
Marbles do you know her yeah yeah she
came from us really yeah dude I was in
love with her dude yeah hired out of a
tanning salon oh I could see that McAfee
Pat McAfee was us really yeah we've had
we have a pretty good like roster how do
you pick Talent like do you like now
obviously people end up usually speaking
mostly of people's successes right do
you feel like you've had a good eye for
it or do you feel like you've had just
as many hits and misses what do you
think no we definitely have a good eye
for it and we have misses for sure I
think though the biggest
thing we have an eye for it and we don't
control people at all so you know we
hire somebody and it's like you do you
and and
hopefully they find the word like Caleb
use an example like we saw him uh he was
running up and down the sidelines of
North Carolina he was like because they
wouldn't because he never started yeah
and it but he wasn't even uniform his
his title was like I think the professor
of morale or director of morale so he
had his blonde hair he'd wear like a a x
North Carolina professional football
player who's now in the league their
number we saw him on TV like who the
[__] is this kid we had him on one of
our shows like oh he's got a weird brain
that's what we say like we look for
weird brains yeah he does and we hired
him and it's like yeah do whatever you
want and you know he kind of he was
always talented and funny bounced around
kind of trying to find his Niche and
then he the Sunday conversation which is
now his his kind of trademark thing and
is great that took a couple years for
him to like
fit that exact perfect role and we just
let people sort of do that so I think
it's the combo we have a good eye for
talent but more so we we are so free in
in letting and I don't know if that's
just we're lazy or whatever but we never
tell people right what to do it's like
you're hired we'll give you the
resources do whatever you want and we've
had a lot of hits because of it like PMT
which is Big Cat yeah dude like that was
all his idea I mean totally
like I thought podcast when when I first
heard about podcasting a guy Kevin
Clancy who's been with us forever oh
yeah yeah like that's a stupid idea
podcast you'll never make money doing
that but they [__] did it um
obviously they were smarter than me call
her daddy that came from us yeah yeah
Alice Cooper so yeah we've had a lot of
uh
a lot a lot of big big successful people
that really were I mean McAfee played in
the NFL but no one knew him on the media
side a lot of big people that million
dollars worth of game is a huge like
Urban podcast with us right now
um so yeah we've had a lot of big
successes Caleb whenever I got to know
Caleb one thing he Raves about is that
he loves working for you yeah he he's
he's been great I think I mean he
genuinely like you know what I'm saying
like some people say my job but he has I
mean he absolutely loves it
that probably he likes working for us me
is the freedom which I just said and I
always do what I say so
I have the back of the talent as much as
I can always but like if I say something
it's it's Bond I actually think in his
contract he has something like when Penn
bought us he's like if there's a
disagreement between Penn and me or
something like Dave gets to make the
final decision he just so he just trusts
that he is good to work for somebody
where you you know you can trust like
they have your best interest and I do
and some people may not like what I say
or do but I'm pretty straightforward and
the track words is like there like 20
years I've been pretty consistently
straightforward honest truthful yeah
is there a higher or a departure that
you regret or that you like somebody
that you let go or anything or did you
have any no I mean we we hired Mike
Rapaport this is a big [__] I don't
like that guy right now uh he doesn't
like me he doesn't like me that was at
the Block like I I literally
if I throw a punch I've never been a
fight in my life never thrown a punch in
Anger if I threw a punch right now with
my left arm it would dislocate that's
how [__] up my shoulders are he got me
so mad I sent him a contract to fight
him like that's how [__] that ended
terribly uh the McAfee thing with us
didn't end great but like I don't really
have regrets he was always going to be
like a huge star on his own he's so good
at so many things so no not not too much
yeah I mean we're we've become to a
degree
and I always said a Saturday Night Live
model like we bring unknown talent and
try to make them stars and we'll keep
them as long as we can keep them but
really you know if we can't hopefully
they go become big somewhere else and it
adds more credibility for us right
because then people like oh this is a
place where I can get a start and build
my name and either stay with Barstool or
not we've been pretty good at that hope
you enjoyed that video and you can watch
another and you can watch this one you
can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one